[Applause]
you say something nice about me i tear
up i i'm not used to hearing stuff like
that
yes that is what i'm trying to do
and the shows the shows it's happening
remember when this was just you talking
about it yeah but you showed up
you know for me when i was trying to do
i it was we were calling it a pilot but
straight up it was a full-blown audition
it was a full sales tape and we had to
wait months
to find out if we were really going to
get the job
and then of course the pandemic broke
out and you know we had to keep going
not knowing if we were really going to
do it or not but i just thank you
because i
i just don't really do any endeavors in
this world that are
meaningful and important to me without
doing it with you so
thank you for doing that we are a team
on on all that movies were a team
the show that was not a problem at all
ever ever and you
calling me up and saying you want to
give me 16 points
of the show that's too much
true you can have 16 points of anything
in my life you can have infinite points
but by the way when i came to
like get my you know pretend to be
barbara walters
um with you in boston you were on the
set
of huby halloween growing up and even
now whenever a sitcom was on
and it happened to be the halloween
special that year
i got more excited than anything even if
they mentioned hanukkah
i was like that's great but let's get
back to the halloween of it all
right we haven't had a comedy a
halloween
comedy like this i mean i thought about
like hocus pocus
and someone was like goosebumps and i
was like yeah but that's really
kids that's like that skews very young
this is a little more we hope the kids
can like it but it is a little ruckus at
times yes yes it gets a little
disgusting at times
i think this is huge that was the
intention
the intention was let's make something
huge let's have me
look very goofy in it and i handle that
with grace
i love huby dooby so much it reminded me
of like
water boy and you know
it felt like such a strong character
very goofy kid he he has he lives with
his mama
just like bobby boucher did in the water
boy
water boy by the way came right after a
movie called the wedding singer do you
ever see the wedding singer
drew lucy doesn't remember the wedding
singer but
julia does julia
goulia uh and we couldn't let that
happen you had you had to
you had to get over to the better guy
oh my god wait i'm serious though i
really think
that you have done something here
that but people this is epic
i really can't think of a halloween
comedy and there are so many amazing
comedians in it you've got
stiller opening it and you know
kevin james and julie bowen and tim
meadows
and it just and ray leota and
bushemi uh my listen uh
and and all the youngsters are in it all
these young uh funny
kids i kept i kept uh i watched those
shows with my
my daughters you know like all the uh
disney and nickelodeon and all that
stuff on netflix and
and uh we were writing parts for
uh you know people like 17
18 19 years old so i was like oh that
kid from that show that that kid's great
let's see if they'll do it and um
so there's a lot of youth in the movie
also
including sunny and sadie and jackie
it's a total family affair
yes they got some they got they had some
stuff to do you know
drew you would think the kids would be
uh very excited in an entire movie to be
in a movie
by around i'd say if they're in a movie
and they get to set around
at eight i'd say around 9 20 i'm hearing
how much more please let me leave
you know they uh they make it look like
i'm forcing them to do it meanwhile they
were asking me the whole damn year can i
be in your next movie daddy
because movies take a long time the days
are
long and by the way are they working
like special hours because of their age
or are they like
no working full-time i i think i hide
them out in my trailer they hang out
they got their friends anyways and then
i knock on the door they go they're
ready let's go
and they're like had always played crazy
like they didn't know they were shooting
a movie i go yeah you don't have your
makeup on they're like
no i'll do it now
disgusting drew you know that hi
everybody
if you are into that i think if you
subscribe we might be able to find each
other again